[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm kitty HD here
and this is a video dedicated entirely
to the performance of the new Mac Pro so
this is a bit of a preview leading up to
the full review that I'm working on of
the Mac Pro but I mentioned a little bit
in my unboxing and first impressions
video that I got the 8 core Mac Pro for
a reason over the 12 core I actually
opted for the 8 core model for a couple
of reasons that'll go into but
essentially this is all the benchmarks
and sort of performance tests that I
thought would make sense for apples only
workstation grade machine so there are a
couple of key benchmarking apps that a
lot of people use to benchmark Macs and
all sorts of desktop machines that you
guys shared with me on Twitter and
things that I've used in past projects
including the fastest Mac Mini in the
world project and the hackintosh Pro
project so the first of these is called
black magic disk speed test and
essentially this just measures the read
and write speeds that are gonna be
capable of on the Mac Pros PCI base SSDs
so if you'll recall the fastest Mac Mini
in the world project had a single vertex
4 SSD and the hackintosh Pro project had
a pair of SSDs in raid 0 but as you can
see by the numbers neither of these
compared to the results of the PCI base
SSDs in the new Mac Pro and that's gonna
get you some crazy fast program opening
times and data access all right so the
next test is a very popular Geekbench
app you've probably seen it already run
on phones and tablets everything from
the iPhone all the way up to the
previous generation Mac Pro so as a
benchmark the fastest Mac Mini in the
world project score at around 10,000 on
Geekbench that actually wasn't shown in
the video series interesting lina and
the hackintosh pro actually scored
fifteen thousand eight hundred and
actually i want to be clear here these
are the multi-threaded scores as
Geekbench 3 here will always kick out a
pair of scores a single-threaded score
and a multi-threaded score so Geekbench
on this Mac Pro kicked out without
screen recording on 3600 for the single
credit score and 26 thousand for the
multi-threaded score and I'll give more
context on these in a second so the next
test is called Nova bench it's a less
popular benchmarking app a lot of people
don't use it but since I've used it in
my two previous projects then I figured
I'd continue to use it now for a
benchmark so it scored roughly 800 ish
on the fastest Mac Mini in the world
and roughly 1600 on the hackintosh Pro
now even though it looks fairly
comprehensive it's definitely an older
benchmark and I don't even know if all
the numbers looked right when looking at
the composition for the final score but
either way the final score here in Nova
Bench was a much higher 2200 on the Mac
Pro now last but not least in the
benchmarking department is called
Cinebench and actually think that
Cinebench is one of the most accurate
overall all-encompassing benchmark apps
you can use it tests both the GPU side
and the CPU side of things and there was
a really wide range of scores you can
get so on the GPU side this Mac Pro has
the absolute highest end dual AMD
FirePro d700 workstation grade graphics
cards with 6 gigs of video RAM each and
these absolutely killed it topping out
the benchmark at an average of 86 frames
per second this isn't necessarily a
representation of gaming performance
because they're not gaming cards but
more of just how much power you have at
your disposal with these cards in here
that a number of production suites and
applications can take advantage of and
on the CPU side this is the 8 core beast
like I mentioned and it ended up with a
score of 1223 which is surprisingly not
that far behind the 12 core Mac Pro at
all and that's actually what impressed
me the most but honestly with 8 cores 16
threads you kind of expect it to crush
benchmarks and it absolutely did so it's
really easy to tell by all these
benchmark results that the Mac Pro is
clearly a very fast very powerful
machine but that brings us back to the
question why did I go with the 8 core
Mac Pro over a 12 core Mac Pro and the
simple answer to that is single core
single-threaded performance there is a
four core six core eight core and twelve
core version of the Mac Pro and each
time you move up in
of course you move down in clock speed
from 3.7 gigahertz to 3.5 to 3.0 22.7
but the thing is higher clock speeds
mean better single core performance for
everyday apps but more cores in general
means better multi-core performance for
the bigger apps that can take advantage
of it so the four core Mac Pro would be
like driving a van down the parkway you
know pretty fast but also still pretty
strong where the 12 core Mac Pro on the
other hand would be an 18-wheeler cab
definitely not the quickest thing in the
world but there is no way anything is
going to slow it down even the heaviest
of tasks so the eight core Mac Pro would
fall somewhere in the middle so at the
end of the day as a person that's using
the Mac Pro as both a beast of a video
editing rig and a day to day machine it
makes sense to have a nice balance
between amazing multi-threaded
performance and nice single core and
everyday use performance which means
when I'm running around videos in Adobe
Premiere or projects in Photoshop and
things like that all eight cores are
gonna be kicking in and it's gonna take
full advantage of that but at the same
time at 3 gigahertz on a single core
apps like Google Chrome and just
browsing around the internet watching
YouTube videos day to day things like
that will also be quick and they won't
be quite as slow as they would have been
on the massive 12 course so there's the
reasoning and there's the performance of
the 2013 Mac Pro but there's a lot more
information about that coming up
especially in the full review video
which is in the works and on its way
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next video peace
[Music]